first time I met Al Pacino I had to meet
a driver in Manhattan had to get into
his car to drive me to The Brownstone
that Pacino was living in so I go
upstairs and I walk in the room there's
Al Pacino David Mamet do I have that
right and Elliott Gould and they're
playing Atari baseball and I'm here to
train the dog they're in the other room
playing baseball I'm saying hello now
guy and you got to learn how to do this
I'm not coming over every day to train
your dog and so they said well why don't
you join us and play some baseball with
us we need a fourth that was the first
time I met him after that and he got
stoned with him I didn't get someone
after that after that he had another
house in Westchester County I went there
working with his dogs lucky and Susie
and that's the point where he was
getting ready to do Scarface so when I
was in the house I was training the dog
he was another room right here you
cockroach all these different
things he was practicing but then the
funny part about it was he kind of he
grew up in an Italian neighborhood
Italians and Jews very similar and all
they kept saying yo Juan you want a
sandwich hungry you want a sandwich nice
guy really nice guy wow really nice guy